you begin with this in Washington where
they're singing that shaggy song it
wasn't me
a string of official denials has failed
to end a guessing game looking for the
name of an anonymous trump
administration official who blistered
the president in the pages of the New
York Times at least 28 senior officials
more than half of them from the
president's cabinet denied writing that
op-ed at a rally in Montana last night
the president blamed deep state
operatives even though the person is a
trump appointee he said they're working
to defy the voters and are a threat to
American democracy Hoosier Jang is
traveling with the president she's in
Billings Montana we should good morning
good morning Nora president Trump
quickly went off script while stumping
for congressional candidates here as he
so often does the president expressed
annoyance over the anonymity of that
op-ed because as he put it there's no
way to discredit the author look at this
horrible thing too took place today it's
really is it subversion is it treason
President Trump continued on the warpath
he has paved against the New York Times
for publishing an op-ed it says was
written by a senior administration
official for the sake of our national
security
the New York Times should publish his
name at once I think their reporters
should go and investigate who it is the
anonymous piece paints a stunning
picture of what the author describes as
anti Trump resistance inside the White
House claiming he's among those working
diligently from within to frustrate
parts of his agenda and his worst
inclinations in Washington the
revelations set off a wild guessing game
the vice president
that was my first saw and a flurry of
denials from the president's inner
circle I think it's a disgrace it's not
mine
nearly every cabinet member issued a
statement to cross their name off the
list of potential suspects noticeably
missing Attorney General Jeff Sessions
who's locked in a feud with mr. Trump
over his refusal in the Russia
investigation the Department of Justice
pointed instead to press secretary Sarah
Sanders his remarks calling the author a
gutless loser despite the claims in the
explosive editorial the president
reassured supporters he's fit for the
job I listen is she competent I think
I'm pretty confident right in a rare
statement First Lady Melania Trump also
slammed the op-ed saying that the writer
is sabotaging the country with cowardly
actions the president urged people to
vote in the midterm elections warning
that Democrats want to impeach him but
he posed this question how do you
impeach somebody who's doing a great job
John Weiser thanks